as we take a look at what zac frankie
has done on the year he's really been
the one guy who's been able to to get
some quality starts for the astros in a
season where they haven't had a lot of
good starts he's essentially been the
one guy that can get past or just get to
the sixth inning and get past it
everybody else in that rotation has not
gotten to that point they need more
people like zach greinke getting deep in
these gains especially during this
stretch they're on right now trout hit
by a pitch last night
and not in the lineup today he was hit
by a christian javier pitch in his
second plate appearance yesterday so
here is walsh you win one for four and
he comes in tenth in the american league
with a 321 batting average
a little tapper coming home is fletcher
and zach's going to look him back to
third and throw the ball into the runner
so fletcher will now score they're going
to call interference on the runner for
being inside the baseline pujols is
arguing with o'norah here comes joe
madden to argue with brian o'nora but
the runner is going to be out
and that should be a dead ball sending
fletcher back to third and ohtani back
to first that's one of those judgment
calls i don't think this is reviewable
either and don't be surprised to hear
that zach cranky did that on purpose a
veteran knowing that sees him inside the
line and hits the runner going down
pujols is hitting 229 275 on base
percentage three homers eight rbis the
2-2
and pujols lifts this one deep to left
center field going back on it as
brantley calling off the center fielder
straw and makes the catch on the warning
track in front of the visitors bullpen
it was scary when it came off the bat
but the ballpark able to hold it
andrew heaney left-handed pitcher fourth
start of the year 14 and a third innings
a whole bunch of strikeouts to go along
with it
and you can see last couple of starts
what he has done he's really pulled it
back together after getting knocked
around by the white sox better command
of his pitches 90-95 with his fastball
curveball has been really really good
and change-up
here's the o2 pitch and he gets him to
chase a high fastball and threw it by
him the fastball upstairs yeah he was
looking breaking ball one and one to
count on bregman he was three for four
last night
boom a breaking ball base hit left field
i'm not sure who has quicker hands than
him i know there are those that match
him but boy his hands are quick that
curveball in the strike zone but still
you mentioned bringing his hands in on
that one
all of a sudden alex bregman getting hot
last couple of games here's heni's pitch
this is chopped on the right side
fletcher with the shift on playing on
the outfield grass will field and throw
it albert and they easily get alvarez
the inning is over on a 4-3 ground out
on with a one out single angels have had
three hits by the first seven batters
against grinky but still looking to get
something on the board against them and
it will bring up scott shepler
shepler drives that one toward the
corner and right that one is down
hustling on around
into the corner it goes disappears it's
a ground rule double he's got shadler
turns on that but gets it in the corner
for a double his second double of the
season angels have another threat
brewing here with one out runners at
second and third and the batter will be
boom here comes the one-two
swing and a miss got him on the
change-up so both of grinky strikeouts
this inning have been on that change and
now the infield can back up with two out
it's almost as fast as his fastball but
he's got great arm speed on it and great
late movement
now it's david fletcher he's singled to
begin the game for the angels ground
ball through the right side iglesias off
third shebler off second the 2-2
curve ball and that's poked in the air
on the infield guriel to his right makes
the catch while standing on the infield
dirt and the inning draws to the close
anders not enjoying the the rub up of
the baseballs tonight
it's a handful of times he's gotten a
new baseball and
they're gonna have a conversation about
the baseballs
he's going to give a a selection which
one does he want to pick from
nope that's out
ryan o'norah the home plate umpire
they're trying to work through it green
i'm not sure why joe man's coming out or
getting the umpires involved but they
look a little bit brighter to me today
than maybe normal and sometimes more
often than not a pitcher will complain
about them not being rubbed up enough
here's the next pitch and on that two
strike delivery that was heaney's best
fastball the night at 95 he threw that
one right by maldonado struck him out
30 year old outfielder playing center
field tonight in place of mike trout
scoreless game both starting pitchers
have been mighty tough in this one first
pitch and this is a ball lined in the
gap in left center field it'll split the
outfielders just getting to it
is straw and at second base with his
second double of the ball game but the
angels have something brewing again here
against crinky runners at the corners
one out and ohtani will be the next
batter
a grunt and a shot in the right field he
was ready for the fastball all the noise
that went along with it shohei otani
with an rbi that's another well hit
baseball on the first pitch he tried to
run that fastball in on ohtani the jam
them but ohtani brings his hands up
that's a pretty good pitch by grenky but
even a better swing and approach for
shohei ohtani jared walsh he's gone oh
for two he's hit into a double play
a little spinning ground ball against
the shift swung all the way around
that's a run for the halos everybody's
safe
nice job by brian butterfield third base
coach as well and joey otani going to
third as a smile from jared walsh not a
lot of exit velocity on that one but
it's an rbi single
led miss diaz will be the next batter
diving play long throw from his knees
got him
what a play by jose rojas
they may look at that one got a lot on
that throw for the knees oh
jose
what a play by rojas has to leave his
feet to his left from his knees fires a
strike over to albert a big exhale son
absolutely one more big challenge for
you out there and that's michael
brantley
go to pitch and he chased a high inside
fastball and struck him out boy that was
up around brantley's shoulders there and
he went after that pitcher pitch came
closer to hitting him than him hitting
the ball
and that will end the inning he strikes
out the side here's fletcher
nice play by cranky to second for one
diaz turns the double play
six straight gold glove awards before
last season and zach wants to start a
new string this year two to nothing to
score d inning meaning decision inning
for this left-hander and all likelihood
is final inning and what will his final
statement be
they've had only two base runners here's
the pitch and bregman chases that one
and that curveball is strikeout number
10 of the night for andrew haney
jordan goes the other way and that is a
fair ball down the left field line
heading to the corner alvarez getting to
second base with a stand-up double he's
there with one away for the astros in
the seventh he will leave the game
allowing his second hit of the night
guerrielle 0 for two so far he's
grounded out and struck out
gilly tries one deep to left field this
game is tied
la pina with a two-run home run
and we're all knotted up
trying to hold up he goes around pressly
gets the strikeout he pumps his fist
coming off the mound and the astros will
try and walk it off in the bottom half
of the inning extra inning baseball for
the first time in 2021 the astros did
not fare well last year with the new
rule
he goes to the right side they say let
him hit it is down
boom they'll send him on around to the
plate the relay the slide the angels
lady and a guy like albert look out
right here that gets the juices flowing
again
albert into center field with a base hit
come on down albert bullholtz gets it
done
correa over four tonight in his second
career game as a leadoff hitter
correa fly ball to right field straw
will tag up
walsh camps under it should be deep
enough with straw speed castro heading
to third straw safe we're tied at four
nobel garcia the switch hitter gets a
chance now
little shot towards center that's a
game-winner
romel garcia
walks it off